I'm pleased to say that we are joined by
Richard Curtis right now Richard Curtis
good morning to you a real pleasure to
have you on the show this morning tell
us a little bit about why you decided to
start this campaign
well the other side of my career has
always been uh comic relief and I think
that you know it's incredibly important
that we deal with the issue of climate
these days you know which is not only to
do with the planet but harming enormous
number of people on the planet and the
big question is what we can effectively
do and the biggest resource that normal
people have is where their money goes
and our banks where we're investing our
money are in fact huge investors in
fossil fuels but particularly fossil
fuel expansion so the top you know High
Street banks have given 140 billion to
companies that are expanding fossil
fuels and we know that if we're going to
keep the temperature down you can't have
expansion you can't have new things the
bank should be putting all that money
into you know Wonderful renewable uh
energy and affordable housing and all
the good things that they could be
spending for but they're not behind our
backs they're actually investing in just
the things that we all don't want to
happen
now you'll know there's part of cop 26
there was the G fans the Glasgow
Financial Alliance for Net Zero
initiative set up by Mark Carney former
governor of the bank of England which is
all about trying to get these Banks to
to reach Net Zero are you not happy that
that has gone far enough
well it's it's definitely not happening
fast enough and what we believe is that
people you know if you talk to people
they think that Banks need to do more
and most people think that the banks
shouldn't be investing in fossil fuel
expansion so yeah we're just trying to
forcefully prod you know we've got
Greenpeace save the children Emma
Thompson Deborah Mead and everybody who
we wrote to said this sounds absolutely
right the bank should know that their
clients want them to be on the side of
solving the problem not sort of sneaking
around behind our backs investing in
things which are gonna you know leave a
ghastly situation for our children I
mean we're just seeing climate change
and its tragedies all around us and we
have the power by saying to our banks
let's actually get out of this stuff to
really make decisive change you know if
you're recycling if you're throwing away
if you're not using plastic bottles uh
if you're you know all of those things
do this too get in touch with your bank
and say come on you can be the necessary
Heroes rather than not doing it and I
think it'd be a shock to most people
that the High Street Banks aren't at the
moment pulling their weight yeah and
just this morning this reporting in the
financial times average I don't know if
you've seen it that some banks said that
they couldn't sort of cooperate in this
sort of way because they might fulfill
of competition or now it's being
reported that that's going to be changed
to allow them to sort of all work
together in the same direction precisely
around these sort of things I mean I
guess you must be pleased to see that
that looks like it's a step forward
yeah and you know actually two of the
High Street banks have started to make
this commitment so it is Shifting that's
where public pressure comes into it and
you know it's not that the banks are
going to lose money when I spoke to Mark
Carney he said that
um you know sustainability is the
greatest investment opportunity since
the Industrial Revolution so actually we
want our banks to be both smart and
doing the right things and the the
climate crisis requires everyone to do
everything to get where we want to and
surely the banks who have our money who
we trust with our lives in that way
should be leaders not laggards
and she goes well while I have you I
will have to talk about the movie
business and your work if you don't mind
um and I think you are working on
something at the moment can you can you
tell us anything about some of the stuff
we could expect to be coming from from
your pen soon
uh yeah I mean first go to the make my
money manager website and tell your bank
what you think about because it's so
important
um at the moment I'm actually doing a I
wrote a film with Lenny Henry called
Bernard and the genie about 20 years ago
and we're
um doing a new version of that where the
genie is now Melissa McCarthy so it's
going to be a very different film and I
think a lot of fun I'm such a huge fan
of hers yeah I had a little Google about
that it's going to be set in New York
and that's going to be coming pretty
soon huh yeah that's right excellent
stuff so I guess
SCA do is playing uh Bernard so I'm
excited about that but mainly I want to
solve the climate crisis and do it now
and so tell your bank what you think and
get them to be the things that lead the
change rather than the people that you
know uh
stop it happening
all right you made your point very first
we usually it's a real pleasure to talk
to you and we've got a little sneak
preview about the work here you're
looking forward to next so would you
guys appreciate your time thanks for
being with us thank you great